[Music]
at QuakeCon 2018 its software just
showed off a ton of doom eternal
gameplay and while they did touch on the
new demons weapons and areas that you'll
see in the game there are still a few
things that deserve a closer look so
we're gonna put the footage under a
microscope and see just what Bethesda is
cooking up with our second serving up
hell on earth
here are ten things you might have
missed during the doom eternal
presentation some of the weapons from
doom 2016 have returned but they feature
some subtle changes that you might have
missed
for example the shotgun now has an
alternate fire that's basically a
Gatling gun while the plasma rifle
shoots orbs that Electrify enemies some
of the weapons have been completely
revamped like the ballista which is now
a new version of the Gauss cannon
instead of the siege mode it shoots
energy bolts that explode on impact now
these are only a handful of changes but
I'm hoping they'll bring out new
elements for all the weapons this time
around there appears to be some sort of
life system because around the end of
the first gameplay clip the player
grabbed a plus 1 life item and it's
likely that this item is useful during
enemy invasions but we have to wonder if
it serves a specific use when playing
only in single-player ok it's really
hard to miss this one unless you stop
the video early but it appears that doom
eternal is actually following on the
promise of its predecessors conclusion
by giving you the crucible sword and
letting you use it in battle now whether
or not this becomes a mainstay in your
arsenal is still yet to be seen but
we're down to slice up some Cacodemons
for at least a portion of the game when
they opened up the map screen it showed
a ton of question marks which are likely
secrets for you to discover
but given just how enormous the map is
now compared to doom 2016 maybe all
these secrets are alluding to a deeper
emphasis on a metroidlike exploration
and backtracking there are a bunch of
new glory kills now I know a lot of them
are pretty obvious and you might have
seen them but I just really want to show
this guy getting his head squashed into
his body again
ooh it looks like The BFG is back and
it's a lot bigger than I remembered
during the scene where doom guy is
taking the elevator down to Phobos you
can actually hear over the loudspeaker a
voice talking about The BFG 10,000 and
it's that thing right there
while nobody really knows exactly what
it's firing at we're hoping that some
sort of gigantic demon that will
eventually face in the game in case you
missed it doom eternal added a bunch of
mobility options to doom guy for one he
has two dashes that he can use as shown
by the indicator right here on the UI
but what you might have missed is that
there are also polls that you'll be able
to swing on and also walls that you'll
be able to climb also the grappling hook
that they use all throughout the demo
can be used to cover ground really
quickly doom 2016 was all about moving
forward and having that momentum and
doom eternal looks like it's gonna take
that even further early on in the
presentation we saw doom guy's new suit
which was equipped with a blade that he
uses for the new glory kills and also a
shoulder-mounted launcher that can shoot
grenades and spewed fire but knowing
dooms tend to c4 over-the-top weaponry
there is no way that that's all it does
there's a possibility that we might get
more weapons for this thing and unlike
doom 2016's grenade will actually use it
this time around also during the
presentation they announced destructible
demons now it's a little hard to see
amidst all the shooting and the blood
splattering but there appears to be some
nuance in the way that these enemies get
destroyed demons will now lose their
armor as you can see right here get
visible holes blown through them or even
begin burning alive after shooting them
enough times
like the older games you can nab
power-ups that will enhance her physical
characteristics previously these buffs
were limited time only deal but in doom
eternal they seem to be permanent at
least from what it looks like
you see doom guy grab a blood punch
powerup which increases the damage of a
melee attack after a glory kill but
there's no timer on it leading me to
believe that there will be more of these
non temporary power-ups in the future
though it's unclear what happens to your
existing powerup when you grab a new one
but I'm guessing you're likely going to
have to pick and choose for which one
you want to keep so those were the
things that are keen eyes picked up
during the doom eternal presentation but
there's bound to be more stuff that we
missed if you found any make sure to
leave it in the comments below
and remember to check back on
gamespot.com for even more doom eternal
coverage thanks for watching and I'll
see you guys in hell
[Music]